there's a judge in Connecticut Superior
Court Judge William Clark who has just
ordered the results of a recent mayoral
primary election in Bridgeport
Connecticut State's largest city to be
overturned and for a new election to be
held so not just well we found some
issues but no no no this election is
null and void we were going to hold a
new election that's how bad the rigging
was the judge came down and said that
bridgeport's incumbent mayor Joe ganam
won the election as a result of
significant fraud and what kind of fraud
you guessed it fraud involving absentee
ballots the volume of evidence in this
case he writes including many hundreds
of hours of video surveillance disclosed
and accepted into evidence is perhaps
unprecedented in the state of
Connecticut in an election
case you've got video after video after
video as some are seeing in the 2020
presidential election